servus skills und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute nehme ich euch
mal zu einem treten mit
über
so jetzt fragte ich wahrscheinlich ok
warum bilder pizza und sehr zum training
mitnehmen ganz einfach weil ich auf
meinem kanal eben meine ganze
persönlichkeit zum tragen bringen möchte
und nicht damit ich mein kraft oder
akinator ausspielen möchte und zum sport
ist ein wichtiger bestandteil in meinem
leben ich trainiere momentan jeden
zweiten tag seit vier tagen
und dazu kommt natürlich auch noch dass
ich gerne abwechslungsreichen content
für euch bringen möchte ich möchte nicht
nur jeden tag die krassesten as [ __ ]
secrets 35 geile secrets vorstellen oder
funktionierende holz vibrator in
minecraft es möglich auch nicht jeden
tag mache ich möchte ich bisschen
abwechslung bringen wie gesagt deswegen
geht es heute zum training
ok ich wollte jetzt eigentlich gerade
sony sony so klink oder so was hatten
sie jetzt natürlich nicht da deswegen
kann man hat schon gesehen so ein paar
alien wasser geholt möchte nur kurz
anmerken dass ich jetzt einfach schon
hier im sitzen schon schmelzen
es sind 30 grad ich möchte eigentlich
gar nicht wissen wie das gleiche
60 motto das gute daran dass es jetzt so
heiß ist dass keiner außer mir so
verrückt ist um 15 uhr 30 grad raus zu
gehen auf dem spielplatz geschweige denn
draußen sport zu machen
das heißt ich hab den ganzen sport was
für mich alleine und wir legen los mit
einer kurzen aufwärmübung ich glaube es
ist schon gestört waren deswegen machen
wir noch lange ich würde sagen so fünf
bis zehn minuten seilspringen
okay leute was wollte machen ganz easy
fünf sätze kind züge abwechseln mit fünf
sätzen dips danach ein bisschen ruhiger
tag ich bin sak und das ist die klimmzug
surf challenge
alter des landes gestört heißt pac-man
mein handy sei vorweg kopf diesen weg
sieht er die noch nein also
die leute die hitze ist schon leicht
zerstörerisch muss ich sagen leute ist
so wichtig dass über limite viel trinken
fahrt ging weiter so noch kurze ansage
zwischendurch veralbert wie jetzt schon
in die kommentare schreiben
oh mein gott mein gott er ist 20 und
macht noch acht teams in acht und habe
schon im mutterleib 10.000 klimmzüge am
stück geschafft ja ihr könnt natürlich
auch wie immer gerne stores in die
kommentare schreiben
wer schon vor seiner geburt hin züge
gemacht hat und wer schon als seine
eltern daran gedacht haben ihn zu zeugen
schon liegestützen gemacht haben so
magma libyen attackiert mich auch so
heftig alles klar
ich sag euch heute die bienen war mich
so richtig rasieren heute hat eben schon
an meinem bein waffen darunter meinem
bein er auf einmal so die biene zu sagen
so arme nach kulterer sich zurück wir
haben zuletzt moment noch ihr geht
becker scheucht
okay leute das war's soweit von dem
heutigen training ich hoffe ich sofort
gefallen da wird viel viel viel viel
material aber nicht viel geredet ich
hoffe es kommen was auch nichts bei rum
für euch wenn es so war dann lasst ein
ei da wie immer achtet darauf ist nicht
von mücken oder bienen gestochen werde
da draußen und bis zum nächsten mal
haut rein